أريد أن أشير إلى ما فعله الرئيس
ترامب في عطلة نهاية الأسبوع هذه بينما كنا
هنا معه في بيدمينستر ،
لقد لعب الجولف مع اتحاد كرة القدم الأميركي لقاعة مشاهير بريت فافر
، ثم أريد أن أريكم هذا الفيديو
من اليوم ، هذا هو
النشاط العام الوحيد  أننا رأيناه
يفعل ، لقد ذهب
خارج ناديه الريفي في
بيدمينستر إلى مجموعة صغيرة من المشجعين وألقوا بأمريكا واحتفظوا بقبعات
أمريكا
الرائعة عليهم بوضوح يمكنك رؤيته
هناك
بدون قناع على ولا أحد من
حاشيته يظهر أيضًا  أن يرتدي قناعًا
في هذا الفيديو ، هكذا قضى الرئيس
ترامب
أسبوعه كما أعلن اليوم أيضًا
أنه لن يكون
قادرًا على
التخلص من الملعب الاحتفالي في
يانكيز لأنه في
ذلك اليوم كان هكذا كان ذاهبًا إلى  كن شديد
التركيز في المستقبل على فيروس كورونا وسيعقد
اجتماعات حول
اللقاحات ، وهذا مجرد سبت آخر
في المستقبل في أغسطس ومرة أخرى لي
ير إلى أنه عندما أمضى نهاية هذا ال
سبوع بالطريقة التي أمضاها ، كان يلعب ال
ولف و  بالطبع قضاء بعض الوقت مع بعض
مؤيديه بيانا ،
نعم ، صورتان خلال عطلة نهاية الأسبوع ،
صورتان دون أن يرتدي قناعًا بعد أيام فقط من
قوله إن ارتداء القناع سيكون
أمرًا وطنيًا ، يبدو أننا
نسحب أقدامنا هنا بشأن هذه القضية